what do i know that you need so bad  that's why you're here  to find out  [Music]  you're not crazy you never have been  do you find yourself drawn to places  you've never been  the visions you've had your entire life  aren't hallucinations  they're memories they're talking about  reincarnation the legend never  dies  we call ourselves the infinite we  remember skills from all our past  lives it takes 10 000 hours to master a  skill  how could you be after a million hours  pretty damn good  what do i know that you need so bad  that's why you're here  to find out we have fought one another  for centuries but you can't stop what's  coming  the end of all things  is he blocked well well well we're gonna  have to reset your memory  you gonna drown me i got a thing about  drowning which is i don't like it  [Music]  you know what man i like you this time  around shut up and turn it on  [Music]  there's still time time  no more time  did you see that  the legend never dies